Mike Pence is running for president a
lot of people don't think he's going to
go very far as president and that's
probably true the poll numbers are not
looking looking very good for Mike Pence
some people are making fun of his
campaign aesthetic and there I think
they're somewhat misguided Mike Pence's
campaign aesthetic is directly out of
the 1980s Mike Pence's campaign
aesthetic is like the the Reagan Bush
t-shirts that you see on college
campuses a lot of the time frat guys
will wear them
Reagan Bush 84
I want to be your president for the
1980s that that is what it's in the
fonts it's in the colors it's in the way
that his photograph is a little bit
faded it
this is all intentional
and it's intentional because Mike Pence
is running as the real return to
normalcy